mon soir d'un huitième remercier d'être
avec nous c'est quoi c'est la pandémie
et sa gestion qui a mis le feu aux
poudres en thaïlande le terrain toujours
connu une vie agitée et politique agitée
depuis nous centrons dehors on est quoi
deux coups d'état 20 constitution et ces
insectes ordinaires ces cas malgré sa
grâce à une fonction publique un solide
la peine qu'on est pas tellement de deux
jeeps qu'en fait de bouleversements mais
ce qui différencie cette fois c'est
trois choses premièrement c'est c'est
une révolte générale de génération c'est
les jeunes qui ont dit ras-le-bol à ces
vieux qui nous dirigent vous avez vous
savez que le car est le seul pays où
pour les lycées on aime on impose la
coupe de cheveux des délits s'ils en ont
ras-le-bol de ça et deuxièmement
deuxième aspect qui est changé c'est que
le rôle du roi avec le roi mohammad issa
le wav agiront comme promis en question
parce que il est un acte politique et il
a fait en sorte que il a de plus en plus
au pouvoir et ils troisième chose qui
ait changé c'est qu'à côté de la
thaïlande en birmanie où nous assistons
à une en arrivant guerre civile parce
que on a eu un gouvernement civil comme
on fait souvent aux calendes d'ailleurs
où on vend ses parts en cumul militaire
donc nous sommes dans une hes dans une
situation où ces trois éléments le vent
de génération l'asb est international et
il aspire le col remise en cause du rôle
du roi se trouvent ensemble donc pour le
premier ministre thaïlandais une
situation compliquée ce mouvement de
contestation auquel on est précisément
son ampleur est ce qu'on doit craindre
des violences a justement l'instar de ce
qui se passe en birmanie pas ce point
parce que les terrains les militaires
allant des contrées normes éditées buman
sont allés groot
il scelle très bien joué et chaud en
fait la conciliation
nous non ce qu'on va assister c'est
simplement que ce mouvement qui était
très fort l'année dernière revient en
force après le candide
ça s'est un peu à crâner cosco vide à
cause des nez c'est quelque chose de
très profond
en fait c'est une vraie révolution comme
on trouve en birmanie c'est une
révolution des jeunes contre les les
justement les délais les vieux qu'il est
plus qu il est du goût vannes et donc ce
n'est pas acceptable c'est une
révolution disons deux côtés du genre
dans ces manifestations beaucoup de
femmes beaucoup de lgbt et aussi c'est
un rejet comment bemani comment aussi en
allant d'une société très chic
donc ça s'appelle une révolution s'est
dit que c'est plus profond que nos
politiques paris les demandes politiques
très précis que prévu démissionne
conscience de constitution parce que
c'est quand même et conditions
antidémocratiques le sénat et il est
nommé n'est pas élu donc et c'est à ce
prix tout à fait raisonnables malgré
sorte de meurtre at d'un changement
politique mais aussi tout fondement
le rejet d'un cité par ea chic et les
jeunes contre les vieux clairement
comment les autorités répondent à cette
colère
ce que elle est à la hauteur justement
de ce mécontentement de la population
mais justement met en prison les
manifestants c'est très classique en lui
ce système judiciaire pour fêter la
l'opposition l'église les droits de
lèse-majesté
c'est sûr pays du mordu il existe des
doigts de l'essai alors les utilisent
pour fêter leur position mais le
problème c'est que les militaires cas et
malgré tous les défauts étaient plutôt
efficace dans la gestion de l'économie
existera pas s'y laisser ça aux
compétences et aux technocrates civile
mais là la réponse du géant à l'iut de
prémunissent tu nous manques allant des
eaux qu'on vide comme dans beaucoup des
pays de l'asie du sud est est pas aussi
ailleurs et bien ce pays
on a bien géré la première vague mais on
n'a pas fait les faucons a fait en
europe pour la vaccination est donc là
ils sont en train de rattraper mais la
gestion a fait leur réputation des
militaires d'être les gestionnaires
efficaces et comme mise encore stock
c'est à dire que tu l'as fait légitime
fait légitime de régime est mise en
cause par ces manifestants merci david
thème vous d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france pendant exposé la
situation thaïlande merci à vous